you are literally blowing into a fan
there they go with a hat
that's pretty advanced for this
competition art versus baby blue oh
bloody hell
I don't know which side the crowd will
be on in this one we have beautiful
handmade crocheted robot versus a toilet
today
then piloted by someone from actual
Robot Wars no way you come out of this
looking good night no matter what lost a
wheel there's a wheel gone that all
so our grand final will tick tack and
pingu please take to the stage 15
seconds the winner has to be for your
astonishing efforts despite failing
immediately I award you this box and the
prize for the winner of havoc on UK
electromagnetic-field 2016 on a very
deserving winner please give it up for
today
that was havoc on we hope you enjoyed
the show
good night thank you our film crew thank
to all the robot is thank you Jim for
running everything I'm gonna get out of
this cookie dough good night